hey everyone welcome to this week's
GameSpot after doc podcast the big
topics this week Animal Crossing dreams
and I'm so sorry for the amount that we
talk about how much we need to pee but
time stamps are in the description below
as always please enjoy
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to episode 29
of GameSpot after dark I'm Lucy James
hosting this week in lieu of Jake Decker
who is in the loo in the lair
yeah joining me on the couch this week
is Dave Klein hey Kelly plaguey hello
and Peter Brown oh I didn't see so let's
kick off this week before we get into
what we've been playing slush watching
slash doing cuz we had the nice little
holiday weekend nice oh yeah we did huh
yeah three days of doing nothing let's
do the Chris from Dayton Ohio segment 2
point 2 so the Chris from Dayton Ohio
segment is the basically like who are
you what do you do we do get everybody
who's new on new show yeah get to know
people know right we should we haven't
really done it with the the song for a
while so the song created by eight more
Hussain written composed and performed
but your mother's name but I will I will
do a cover right now but up but up it
has its own we should I keep I know I
say this every single time but we should
formalize that jingle get some musicians
in go on audio network mm-hmm get some
sweet backing tracks yeah yeah we can
hire you know people who are making
jingles for radio like that's I think
you can be totally budget is for that
yeah that we could use Fiverr just need
a music you know when you pay that five
five bucks there's no quality no
guarantee of quality with fiber but yes
I'm hosting misery gets loose cuz Lucy
exactly ah so the Christmas date in Ohio
segment we're now up to Christmas Dayton
Ohio two point two with the patch notes
from Kevin who sends these in and this
is basically 20 questions to get to know
you
we're gonna do them rapid-fire cally you
and I have done these and answer these
before the patch notes for this week is
a question ten
Kevin's added SMG to cover all usual
options
question 20 he's added Kamiya after
winning our fan poll naturally minor bug
fixes and improvements and he's actually
proof read it to make Jake Jake Jake's
life easy Jake Jake really read I guess
oh me neither
so for clarification crews from Dayton
Ohio originally was the person who asked
us basically who the hell are you
that emails so much and then kevin has
iterated upon it with rapid-fire
questions and that is what all right
Kevin from Kevin you know from Kevin is
from West Hartford Connecticut tip is
your six one zero seven that's where I
was born I grew up in West Hartford
Connecticut no seriously I'm not joking
your oh that's ridiculous
I don't need the 20 questions at this
point Kevin's surname is at any jfilt
Nash felt nation nation felt know you
Kevin Brook Lane right near Duffy
elementary school no one ever talks
about West Hartford we did this the
first time we did the the two point the
first 2.0 before the patches we did it
like you know in a row answering the
question yeah so I asked the question
Dave you don't an MP you know I'll just
sit here and smile you can just like
approvingly nods which take what
wouldn't help you if you're listening to
the audio version of this podcast Kevin
but they'll know they'll know she's
improving Lee nodding or shaking her
head just watch the video approvingly
shakes my head got pleasure yes all
right
number one in mmo's DPS Gila or tank mm
DPS DPS in Pokemon grass fire or water
starter water dress no 3 sonic Oh Mario
Mario Mario that's a joke you won't get
unless you're too video version my pizza
thing I mean YouTube life is strange
walking dead gone home or what remains
of Edith Finch I've only played walking
dead slow with that what remains number
5 a game that's made you the angriest
tarsals still a days no you just go
Elysium maybe I'll talk about it
angry at the writing for a fight
number six mom about Street Fighter II
fire street fighter seven halo overwatch
quake siege or call of duty call of duty
quick eight most desired smash ultimate
edition
like what do you mean in terms of
edition of smash ultimate like a
character like it Oh characters you know
now disk kun wait no Phoenix right I
take it back okay uh number nine Linea
uh open world linear usually
you
I don't know I don't know you now number
10 in first-person shooter games shotgun
SMG assault rifle or sniper rifle
shotgun assault rifle 11 co-op single
player multiplayer single player 12 Xbox
Playstation Nintendo PC oh yeah yeah
Nintendo if it's only those PlayStation
13 unlucky for some favorite controller
ever Oh actually the switch controller
because I hold it like this for people
who can't see I just do the ultimate
lounge position with my arms completely
nice so I love that I can do that with
the switch controller nice uh the Super
Nintendo controller
I guess 14 pop-tarts are toasted strudel
cutters toaster strudel
I smell a sitcom 15 is it cheating if a
friend tells you how to beat apart
you're stuck on nah no 16 is it cheating
if you saves gum nah
I mean hold on what is cheating really
no I don't know I feel like all flush
relationships and apparently everything
is cheating no no save scumming because
you're only using the tools you were
given right if you put on bighead mode
that's cheating what's going okay so
much action replay is one thing yes
Daniel or dan okay for 42.3 that's not
how you spell right good but Dan Reicher
Riker you can plead the fifth on this
set the right way I plug the fist yes is
that the right I don't know Danny add
wire cuz he has the right amendment yeah
thank you he knows too many things about
me
so Daniel Dwyer 18-game on a couch or at
a desk
couch 100% couch oh I mean I would like
also bed to be at it yes but yes have to
bed wins I don't have 19 favorite gaming
snack Oh none I don't I don't like
getting while he game get your hands
messy
garrovick areand merger finally Miyazaki
c'mere Sakurai Miyamoto Kodaka
or Kojima oh geez rockier Miyamoto
I'm gonna go since I'm a Dark Souls
Galgo of Miyazaki but it's such a tossa
hmm I'll go with Miyazaki now currently
Miyazaki only me uh sorry only cuz you
know because there's no one else really
like him mister I heard he was like
Pleasant in the office like really
wonderful to be around when he was here
he's great he was great I was surprised
with the number of people that he and
Chicago brought with them yeah I was
like 8 do you want to just it in Kodaka
sounds defense mm not defense but just
like though I the reason Kodaka is even
on that list is Kodaka because Kodaka
made danganronpa mm-hmm and I
interviewed katana once and I was like
what do you think about like coz coz coz
August whole thing was like I just kind
of made a game that I would like and I
don't think that it would have such a
like a huge fanbase I was like what do
you think about all the people who love
this game so much
he was like I don't see those fans I see
them as na kama all right was like what
does that mean that's the coolest thing
I've ever heard nah come on is like
comrades okay wait hold it hold it
it's just like some fast and furious
[ __ ] worth like people who love that
high school murder [ __ ] we're not c'mon
hey I mean I'm a killer [ __ ] that my
roommate bought me from the Alamo so
Callie you're you're dying on rappo fan
I'm assuming nine nine nine or dangan
ronpa
over nine nine nine yes okay I woulda
said you ask me monsoon now I just want
to put that out there oh we could also
we could get that it in okay so two
point three Kevin you got your your work
cut out for you was that all that was
old then that was twenty that was a
rapid fire here's a question for Kevin
Kevin what high school did you go to
Connor
exactly Connor chieftains or Hall I
don't know what the Hall mascot was
because it was just blue that's all I
have to say kind of so let's go Kevin
what's your home address
I mean don't actually email su home
please don't no please don't yet yes but
you know I do enjoy that yeah I feel
like the significance is not really
being celebrated here but that's really
nuts to me yeah like a small town in a
small state yes very small it's not like
it was like we're both from New York
City do we spell I find that really
weird when for me being in America
because I still can't get over how big
it is
yeah and if I run into someone that I
know on the street I'm like oh my god
hahaha because it's just you can't get
anywhere it's not oh yeah like back in
the UK if I was in London if I wanted to
go see my mum it's three hours on a
train if you go through it first of all
are there trains here I don't know any
directions still in the same buddy state
I think just LA to San Diego is the only
train I really know we had a same track
but it's like it's like a whole thing I
think I tried to take it once and then
we ended up getting a bus instead yeah I
really
I'm really a big I'm really just I'm so
into public transit now like I'm really
like a trained person I'm like we need
the high-speed rail you on MUSC like um
like the tube I want the tube from San
Francisco to LA down now is just like
you say man tube it's like yeah
literally like one or two people at a
time really cuz like yeah last one I saw
the test had like a passenger car at
least that was the idea it was the idea
but I think like now is a year ago the
execution or this cuz it was like yeah
we could fit our car that fits in here
with like a couple of people I'm finally
yeah just like Futurama I'm still fine
with that yeah cuz when you said tube I
thought you meant oh yeah no we'll never
have public transportation that nice no
it's not never said never I mean good
for the infrastructure here is not built
for it no gaps to mind if that's the
really the issue we had more gaps all
right what have you all been playing /
watching / doing um this week Davis done
with you I've finished disco Elysium
mm-hmm I want to talk about it I don't
like it that much and everyone else
loves it so let's talk about the fact
I'm playing a hollow night on steel the
soul mode which is perma death mode
mm-hmm and it's like it's been intense I
played a holla night last year for the
first time picked it up again for the
flight actually because I'm here from LA
and just started plays I just like
what's still soul mode I don't know what
this is I haven't played the game in a
year and it's just it's like a whole new
way to experience it it's such a good
game I like and it's also the perfect
way to prep for a silk song coming out
mm-hmm for everyone who hasn't played a
holiday night it's like a it's a
Metroidvania style game with like Dark
Souls and if you used in the way and
it's just it's really good cuz your
history is you started as a Souls born
youtuber and then you came to work with
us but you work on games what universe
which are entertainment team yes still
dip your toe into souls born every so
often I mean I I'm just more of a
generally like I majored in video game
design and computer science I worked at
Polaris I worked at machinima I've done
a lot of you know Tom knew you wouldn't
you got hired
he was like yeah I know a huge Hills
more guy yeah yes so like my youtube
channel I got known for soul stuff souls
more stuff but not kind of branched out
cuz I mean there's not much souls boring
stuff there was secular but I mean like
I like names in general so it's nice to
branch out but yeah holla nice just like
ah so good for anyone else to play it
it's like one of the best indie games of
the past ten years I think mmm
a friend of mine they're a couple and
they both have matching Hollan night
tattoos it's very cute that's great I
like that leaf I'm playing it on switch
portably is significantly different then
say playing it like on a screen with
that normal controller I mean I played
it for the first time on my switch but
on a TV so it's hard for me to compare
that much yeah I mean like I guess
portably it's a little bit easier
because my TV cuts off the screen a bit
so yeah actually the nice thing about
playing it portably is that since i play
my switch like this as I measure with my
arms completely across like yeah it's
like sometimes I accidentally press the
controller diagonally without realizing
it sure so that's the downfall when
you're playing game like Celeste I've
had so many grouse where I wanted to
throw the controller because of that by
halle night when you're playing it like
handheld you never screw up because
you're holding the controller normally
so that's like the only difference I can
note is that that I pulling our
controller lazy I am so allowing G with
my switch it's the best I mean I would
find a way to screw up holo night anyway
I think holla night intimidates me so
much I haven't played it I feel like it
has a fairly good learning curve though
it's not like so intense it does I think
so I started playing it and I had no
real knowledge of it and what it was
really like and I stopped playing it I
got immediately discouraged and then I
watched MOC Brown games tool kit he did
a really great series I did a couple on
hollow night and I was like oh it's just
now in the unfortunate backlog right
yeah I mean that gets so big backlogs
yeah for anyone who knows holidays I
never play my switch on the Muni mmm
speaking of public transit yeah yeah but
for anyone who knows how the night I
literally right before recording this
just finished that mantis will
it's so and I just start playing it
yesterday so damn see where I get to
before I die and never want to play
permadeath mode again this is like you
do it once you're like never again I got
too far wasted too much time
yeah but it's intense it's why I don't I
like that I like when games but I guess
that's why I like tarsals but I like the
challenge about when like everything
matters so much and you get to that
critical moment it's like I like use
with lives for example like Mega Man and
a lot of people don't like that but I
like when it's so intense when we have
one life left and you're like everything
matters so much and nothing can really
replicate that feeling and that's what
permadeath no feels like so it's fun to
me in that regard I'm sure I'll get
frustrated when I die but until then
it's like it's you're so focused in on
it it's great
damn can't you are selling Halloween to
me but I am playing blood-borne in the
moment so well you know blood-borne is
better honestly I'm sure Sam solely on
blood-borne was well Sam I'm waiting for
him the voice of God cuz using poison to
our room fear the O blood fear the oh
bloody become because no I'm my eyes are
yet to open but your eyes will open no
cuz I keep I keep starting blood-borne
I've started it multiple multiple times
and I'm playing it with someone right
now so it didn't pass the controller
whenever we die
person playing with house finished it
but I because I've started the game so
many times I know the opening area is
really like a suspiciously well yeah so
I'm like oh we need to go around here
and find this bit and but the way that
I'm approaching it I think after playing
Sakura is that I'm like actively being
more careful yes so more aggressive if
that makes sense
I mean blood-borne kind of forces you to
be aggressive sneeze do I have shield
though I mean there were times when I
used to play where I would just back up
and I'd mess up my stamina and I would
just do everything I could to get out of
Dodge rather than now when I'm playing
I'm actively going okay two hits dodge
yeah like recover not recover but sort
of reset a little bit and then so I'm
enjoying it we're kind of blasting
through it I feel like from software
games really prep
for other from software games you know
like you playing sekito you're more
Pratt for blood-borne now yeah it's
weird I'm kind of working backwards
h-bomb okay did a really great video
about how blood-borne similarly teaches
you how to play Dark Soul yeah and that
is you to be more aggressive when you're
playing dog Souls instead of just
turtling behind the shield yeah it's
more fun to play that way too
yeah I think you laughing attending
County what you playing um I mean I I'm
doing Oh seeing eyeing briefly I will
say um I have been trading on Pokemon
home and this is kind of like an oozy
thing because Pokemon home added you can
now get like abilities on Pokemon you
couldn't get before so um like an
example is clefable you couldn't get its
hidden ability and sword and shield I'm
not sure why I don't know what the
reasoning is because there's other
Pokemon you can get their hidden
abilities just fine so I've been going
in Pokemon home and like searching these
hidden ability Pokemon that you can give
before to get them into my games to like
trade with people so I got a bunch I got
like I got a hidden ability clefable and
a hidden ability like it's not it's not
interesting sorry but anyway everything
I've said this before I love hearing you
talk about Pokemon I I mean I just like
we get emails about how much people love
I talk about I have a lot of fun I
really like competitive Pokemon and for
Valentine's Day
my boyfriend bred me a shiny pokemon Wow
which was like it took him he said he
added 20 hours to his save just doing
that but he was like I did leave it on a
little while so it probably wasn't full
20 hours but um it was like one that I
wanted and so now I'm like figuring out
how I'm gonna train it that's fun that's
incredible I feel like I play every
other Pokemon game and I play them in
depth when I play them and I've still
never gotten a single shiny so to me
that's incredibly impressive
my first shiny pokemon that I got like
just I happened to encounter it was in
alpha sapphire so after like 15 years of
playing Pokemon games I finally
encounter
shiny and it was a Whismur and then but
I did find a shiny in shield rant like a
Pokemon can like charge at you right and
yeah and sword and shield and I wasn't
looking I was like I'll play in between
rounds of like siege or something
sometimes because we still play siege
for fun and all like I'll be playing and
I wasn't looking as doing something else
and then when I looked down a Sableye
was running at me and it was shiny and
it looked charged at me and then I got I
was like ah [ __ ] and then I didn't I
like tried to dodge it I didn't and then
it was shiny and I was like look I just
screamed I it's so just open your arms
like charged me every pokemon that tries
to attack me but I've since this is the
first game where I've actually tried to
breach any Pokemon well I guess I caught
some shiny pokemon in let's go because
it was kind of easy it was looking
easiest shinies that you could get into
in the series and then I bred a shiny
Eevee for an Umbreon because they're
like I'm Breanna and you can make it
competitive if you want to and now I
have a shiny Zigzagoon which is what I
really want it it looks like a clown oh
that's what he named it easy
I said cute but I mean like in our it
true-crime loving World's Fair he named
it Gacy
like a serial killer she dressed as a
clown so that's true romance for you
other than that I saw Snow piercer you
did I do yeah so I feel like parasite
kind of ruined me for other bong joon-ho
films because but I haven't seen
memories of murder yet I haven't either
I saw this bug Netflix one that's other
than parasite up Jeff Akshay yeah I
don't I I'm not gonna watch I don't
that's just gonna upset me but um
snowpiercer I felt like it's very much
like a 80s high-concept kind of movie
apocalyptic and I did not enjoy it for
like 75% of the movie
mmm I thought the acting was kind of bad
Chris ever
I have no affinity for Chris Evans yes
Chris I kind of fell off that movie yeah
I liked the ending I did and I'm glad I
saw it through to the end but I but I
was just like did you both love parasite
2 and filling so here's my favorite
movie last maybe some piercers worth
re-watching mind yeah but I didn't get
through the movie so you talk about the
ending like I reacted that because I
actually felt 3/4 the way through kind
of bored with snowpiercer
and it's hard to me to articulate why
now because I watched it when it kind of
came out which is a long time ago the TV
show is coming up very soon that's great
I'm really curious because I don't know
how that's gonna translate the
world-building of it so snowpiercer is
about like a like the world has frozen
over and the last survivors of humanity
live on a train and it's always moving
and it's a it's basically just like
class dynamics the movie but condensed
into this small space and I you know I
kind of hate Tilda Swinton is it
controversial I just I just don't like
her I don't I like how quickly
well-beloved
I'm so curious about snowpiercer though
cuz like I didn't like okiya I I really
I just like Tojo and I finally I like
parasite it was honestly was my favorite
movie the year but I it was good so I
get genuinely really well-crafted movie
the snowpiercer is trailers are good so
that's where I'm like the trailers
intriguing my favorite snowpiercer fact
and I liked the scene too there's a
scene with a fish yes and if you've seen
the movie you'll know the scene unless
you didn't get that far I don't know if
you saw the fish I don't remember much
about the movie now to be honest has
been so long but apparently
a certain wrong and who was involved in
the big wrong in the production if you
watch movie I'll also know who it is
because it's his production company that
produced it didn't want the scene in the
movie and bong joon-ho was like it's a
tribute to my late father who was a
fisherman and then this producer was
like okay I'll let you leave the scene
in the movie and then bong joon-ho after
the movie came out was like so I father
was a fisherman that's cool another
unfortunate thing about that producer is
one of the last films that was released
by his production company when all the
allegations came out was oh but you know
Paddington's so good and wholesome that
he that helps it helps Oh bother
no I'm gonna skip past you thought I
know what we've been doing playing
seeing um you know honestly I haven't
been playing as much as I I would like
to say I've been more doing but still
around games I think with the past like
two years I've been really into
tinkering with electronics and every
month that evolves into me taking a new
console and figuring out okay what does
the community developed around it can I
install this mod using esoteric
knowledge that's really not available in
the places that you'd think when you're
buying a product you think you'd get
instructions how to do it and it's like
now not really so lately I've been
focusing on the world of Game Boy
Advance there's been some new
developments with like the sort of
screens you can install on the Game Boy
Advance yeah yeah so it's actually a
applies all lines of Game Boy now but
there are IPS screen so you can put in
in the past we had like backlit LCD
screens that you could say take out of
the second version of the Gameboy
Advance SP and put into the first one
which had front lit stuff or you could
put it into an older game boy advance
and have the backlit on there the IPS
panels are higher resolution so you get
a crisper image 180-degree pretty much
viewing angle into super sharp contrast
it's been really nice it's been really
fun to play with old consoles and
and get new things out of them using
technology developed by the community
that really loves this stuff so is there
a gameboy advance community oh sure yeah
yeah every system even something like
the 3do recently had a really big like
hey we've got RGB mods out now for the
3do which RGB is sort of like
uncompressed analog video where each
colored channel gets its own dedicated
signal versus something like composite
that takes red green and blue and the
sync line which tells the TV where to
put it all in one and that's why
composites not that good so yeah tapping
into to stuff for old consoles it really
depends on is the community there and
are the engineers there to help support
that community and pretty much every
system has that right now so the next
one I'm kind of looking forward to is
console izing a Virtual Boy yeah people
have installed for the past year or so
kits into a Virtual Boy where you
basically tap into one of the screens
from one of the eyes and you can output
it to your TV or a computer monitor but
now someone who's built a 3-d case where
you take all the guts out of the Virtual
Boy put it in there and you can output
stuff like that do you think that would
work with the Virtual Boy games because
a lot of them really did try to harness
in on that 3d factor some of them did it
I mean some of them didn't but some of
them did yeah I don't I don't think it's
that critical to be honest with you
they're only I'm gonna misrepresent the
number here but like 24 Virtual Boy
games oh it's so small they're not
they're not a ton for me it's it's part
of it is playing the games
part of it is interfacing with the
technology in a modern way and in a way
that's very hands-on for me like for
example when I first started modding
systems I screwed up this pretty
valuable Japanese system and and I kind
of took it as a learning experience also
was upset about it but now about two
years later I was like I'm gonna open
this thing up and I thought it was long
gone but maybe I can fix it it wasn't
like I did something's wrong it was like
I broke off components like things got
mangled I was able to revive it and and
that was like not just for the value of
the hardware which does matter but the
idea that like these hands like I can I
yeah it's super gratifying and
fulfilling but if I'm gonna talk about
you know modern stuff which I should be
in this podcast I think it's like dreams
is the thing right now in front of me
that I'm very interested by and not even
in terms of right now I think dreams is
gonna be a thing and a little big planet
lasted for an entire generation had
three games on whatever we don't need
that from dreams dreams is today what it
needs to be tomorrow yeah and they can
still add fold in new technology and
it's a wonderful in my experience
platform for expression and that's
pretty cool I am curious to see what
dreams yields because I feel like a
little big planet was so within
LittleBigPlanet you know like you had
the game and only if you're a big
LittleBigPlanet fan that that runs
together but like if you're a little big
planet fan it's lonely you really
experience those like creative you know
what people created for the game I'm
hoping dreams goes beyond that yeah and
and I think maybe this is partially what
you're saying but like I hope dreams
stops being a product you have to buy
separate yeah being a PlayStation owner
I think heading into new generation like
what a wooden offer to give people like
hey there's a game engine into this
console yeah but you have access to and
anything else anyone else is making
you're playing go for it
this idea of dream surfing is is really
special but I think like good a little
big planet like the strength of that
series and it's the popularity of it
online was oh this guy made a calculator
can you believe they did something so
complicated sure they're not a little
big planet fans but they'll show up for
that video to watch that with dreams
it's it seems to be a bit more
intangible like what's going to be
impressive in dreams it doesn't
necessarily have to be elaborate it can
be something super simple that just
communicates emotion in a very sincere
way with an effective delivery and yeah
it I've just like seen some things that
are better really cool like like for
example someone's built like a clone of
wipeout the racing game and that's what
it's else is like itself is like oh sick
yeah ship is modern super model super
well I get the sense of speed from that
game but then you then you start to
notice like what are these billboards
for like all around the level and those
billboards in this particular game are
actually other creations and dreams Oh
that there sure yeah you know things
that have taken on a life of their own
within this this universe of creation
that obviously until your embedded in it
it's not going to mean anything to you
but when I think of like an ecosystem of
of games where the community is sort of
tapped into it the potential for dreams
is almost immeasurable and it's it's
crazy this game has been in development
for the entire span of the PlayStation 4
his life cycle for the most part
probably going back a little bit further
here we are finally getting it like on
the dawn of PS 5 like sure ps4 will be
relevant but it almost feels like you
know a game is only relevant for a
certain amount of time if it comes out
we'll talk about it if it doesn't well
have you eclipsed your relevance I think
some people feel that way about dreams
and I feel like that's unfortunate is a
very difficult time telling people what
it was of course because it sounds very
you know I think even in the office
we're talking about it and it's all
people can think about when they talk
about it and my experience is oh well
making the games isn't gonna be as
intuitive but you're not gonna make
something that's as good as what a game
developer makes David Jaffe has a video
on YouTube where in my opinion he very
short-sighted Lee says like no one's
gonna give a [ __ ] about this because if
they're buying it to play games you know
they're not gonna get things that
they're expecting for the $60 purchase
and if they're actually good at making
games they're not gonna make them in
dreams they're gonna make them in like
you know whatever but I think this is
not about making games that pass the
litmus test of what's a great game it's
it's creating something that you can
communicate to someone else in a way
that you can't do via text to be a video
via whatever it's an interactive
experience the sky's the limit in a lot
of ways with dreams and like no I just
so I don't know like what the [ __ ] is
that gonna bear a lot of people got jobs
out of creating mods for Warcraft 3 in
StarCraft so I actually do wonder if
things like a little big planet and it's
already
so what done LittleBigPlanet in the
community yeah so yeah I guess like in
that regard like I mean I wish I had
something like that when I was a kid so
I feel like at least like there's
there's a really good entry level way to
show what you can do if you have
interest without needing to know
programming and all the you know at the
back end which is nice yeah and then
also to Peter's point like seeing what
people create outside of the limitations
of other systems or like outside of the
limitations of the market for making
games to like I mean I I haven't really
messed around with it too much but I I
saw somebody just recreated the starry
valley like Pelican Town mm3d yeah with
the music and you can just walk around
and like it's not it's not like a game
you just get to walk around and that's
one of my favorite games of all time and
it was just cool like I yeah I that was
just a cool thing and but there's also
like meme [ __ ] to you know there's like
we've seen the Joker game no but I saw
the the one where you start off in a
little medieval town and then a huge
Shrek the joka one as Greg was tweeting
about it the other day Greg Miller he
it's a you basically control Joker sort
of like co-op coming down the staircase
yeah vignette fantastic so there's you
know there's really heartfelt things
people expressing themselves I think
it's and and I know that like there's a
lot of curation that goes into it too
like there is some yes there's there's
like kind of like is there like a home
dream there's like dreams surfing or you
can like search for stuff and find
so yeah surfing is the general term for
just literally like I want to engage
with games and move and move through
them in different ways and I think the
sort of stuff you're describing right
like oh yeah I want to find the sonic
levels I want to oh is there one based
on this game I love or like a meme and
like that's gonna be one side of this
game's story which is how it facilitates
social engagement around things that
people already love there's the other
side of it that is the very personal
experience that I don't think is going
to be very easy to communicate to others
because something you know
you have an emotional reaction to
something that clearly is just like
intangible and describable in a way yeah
it looks like crap it doesn't play well
like you know maybe but but you get you
get something from that that's gonna be
the thing that I think gives dreams its
longevity that's going to be somewhat
undefined in like the mainstream
perspective of what dreams is I mean the
fact that it's by default called a game
fundamentally shows that people aren't
well maybe it's not marketed properly as
well but yeah like I don't know dreams
can be so many things it can be a social
media platform it can be an outlet it
can be a source of reconciliation or
relations and it's I don't know it's a
that's that's the sort of thing I'm
really excited about right now I I'm
waiting for big games to come obviously
but dreams is this thing that seems to
be just like bubbling beneath the
surface of like no one's like excited
for dreams and I'm just like why I wish
I wish there was a little bit more
something of that I guess we're
transparency like I did an interview
with Siobhan ready like one of the the
heads of Media Molecule she was like
co-founder and the whole conversation
was how do you bring this game across a
generation like how does that feel to
finally release it her emotions were
effective but it was the stuff they were
telling me about the community where
they literally started crying like in
our meeting a be supposed to bed sorry
I'd be happy happy happy
she does know yeah so she's on the
community side I believe yeah yeah she
actually started crying like in her
meeting just talking about the sort of
things that that happened because they
there's like a hashtag that goes around
and people can like latch on to it to
share their stuff and and it just sounds
like I mean video games can be so
calculated and cold and entertainment
based and frivolous in a lot of ways and
and very personal just to you and it's
hard to really share something unique
between people and it was like god this
thing exists here that just does that
provides that platform for people to
connect and I think my issue with dreams
is being a curmudgeon II old man it
being like I didn't have that when I was
a kid and I'm jealous and I'm hangry
because I want I wish I had that when I
was a kid sure yeah you know I guess
lastly to what kelly was saying the the
dream surfing stuff you can turn it on
auto so it takes you to random things
that's really all I want to use dreams
for I have no
interest in making something myself but
to see a random glimpse into into
someone different than mean like what
they want to say like maybe they're not
all gonna be good
but like Mario maker levels you know
there's some really brilliant ones that
shine and then there's wow
yeah but the variables are still
controlled Mario maker right like dreams
it's like you don't know what you're
gonna get mystery and like no idea I
think one of the most beautiful things
about that is giving people the freedom
to make bad art yeah I think it's just
deviantART the game I think it's
important for people to feel comfortable
making bad things like make bad art like
have your shitty creation but like make
something say something and I feel like
people don't often especially with art I
mean I'm people really don't it's hard
to make money creating things it's it's
just something people don't really get a
lot of support for and and so I I think
it's really special obviously if you
have to buy in the sixty dollars in the
ps4 but like it's nice to not have to
worry about like am I gonna get paid for
this like it's it's it's just like I get
to make my my bad thing that I just want
to make the big question in my mind now
is like our bad thing is worth
preserving of course they are yeah for
some people but not everyone controls
what happens what they make and dreams
it's the one thing I regret not really
asking Siobhan is like it's what happens
ten years from now when dreams die is
like you know like creating a little bit
planet - apparently those servers are
still active Wow
but only because those levels are
forward compatible with three so it's
like the technology just agrees but but
yeah like ultimately you're making all
this stuff will it persists that is kind
of a sad thought actually a little bit
might all go away in ten years we don't
have that with everything I've done in
my career cuz all of my self is online
so you know it was a very common thing I
see a very modern problem okay I went to
art school for four years everything I
made had gone I don't feel bad about it
it's the stuff it's the stuff I got from
it then to me makes sense yeah cuz it
was all it was all stuff I did in the
learning process
maybe now if I saw it I would be like
that wasn't as bad as I thought it was
back then I saw stuff from like
elementary school and I like I loved it
because it's like it's fun to look back
on and be like wow that sucks
do you live close to where you grew up
no I grew up in Chicago okay well I get
home because then I'll just like dig
through all that stuff again and be like
wow I made that thing it was so bad
we're in Chicago
Deerfield North suburb are you from
Chicago
my dad's uh-huh do you know where do you
know where like what part
well my parent my grandparents live in
Geneva now okay and my dad grew up in
Bartlett and Elgin okay I don't know it
might be West Side it's like it's like
anyway oh yeah I it that is a question
like what happens to your stuff when the
technology's in sport anymore but mmm
yeah we're all gonna die stay tuned to
gain a spot for the dreams review it's
not by Peter or me or anybody here but
it'll can we make sure it's spearheaded
or like pinned at the end with we're all
going to die gonna quote Peter no matter
what man the review should have been
made in dreams that's like she
subconsciously pull that idea they did
you know I think yeah they made that
school in dreams in it link that was
that was Simon Cody for under this
that's cool friend of the podcast good
on you Simon Kearney good on you thing
he also made a piece of cheese and he's
been really excited and hoping that
someone would take his cheese and dreams
and use it in something else that's the
other thing yeah I have to make a whole
game you can just make one thing you can
make audio you can make animation like
yeah like you can just it's basically
like the unity store but on the free in
every game or every dream that uses it
you're in the credit oh wow whoa so
people could take your you could be bad
art you could make bad cheese and then
someone could take it remix it and you
know Wow and then you you show up yeah
it's like my vision an internet game in
a way it's very very cool it seems like
a very special game alright let's talk
about news so obviously we're gonna talk
about Animal Crossing
in a little bit Sony has pulled out of
pax
I've never been to a pax I mean that's
adjacent there all right I'm into packs
so the PAX East which is February 27th
to March 1st in cold cold Boston they've
pulled out because of fears of
coronavirus which sucks especially if
you're going to PAX East just play Last
of Us part two because they were gonna
have hands on their yeah Sony and try to
Entertainment made a statement said we
felt this is the safest option as the
situation is changing daily you're
disappointed to cancel our participation
in this event but the health and safety
of our global workforce is our highest
concern yeah and given the noise of the
gamers PAX East is too big it's fine
just go to pax West is better I think
it's a fair thing when it's like yeah
yeah I got a large gathering isn't
unpredictable
I mean mobile what Congress in Barcelona
was fully canceled - yeah really yeah
that's huge
they I was reading something about it
because it was something to do with
their insurance they needed the
government to announce it as an
emergency right yeah the conscience
obviously canceled a massive trade show
yeah like I mean taxis is like huge you
know so many people it's a shame though
cuz like I saw neo 2 is playable and
some other games I'm sure people were
really looking forward to so it's got to
be a huge shame if you're planning on
going but it is understandable yeah I
mean I thought you go to tax and it's
like it's a roll of the dice if if
you're gonna get the PAX pox or PAX
plague yeah yeah it's like roll the dice
are you gonna get it or not and like who
knows with like yeah coronavirus going
around nice thing though there's gonna
be a ton of good games there otherwise
like Sony's stuff missing out is like
yeah yeah but maybe spend that time
looking at things you wouldn't normally
I mean I guess at the end of the day
it's usually about like third-party
developers really an indie developers
like there's so many good indie games
that deserve more attention at those
cons yeah but that's primarily what we
try to do when we go there from the
editorial team anyways like we know you
know the big games already you don't
need us to tell you about those
necessarily but here's some stuff that
you just we really don't always have the
bandwidth to talk about
there's been times where I've like I've
gone to paksas and like gotten games on
my radar that I wouldn't have maybe
known about and then you know being the
person who decides what games get
reviewed it's nice to have like I mean I
like going to paksas because I'm like I
just get a hand along with games and I'm
like oh you know that was really cool I
never gonna make sure we prioritize that
I mean cuz obviously like we can't
review everything yeah it's nice to have
those hands on with smaller games to
kind of get a sense of like is this
something that makes sense for us to do
do you think anyone else is gonna pull
out because Sony pulling out is pretty
huge yeah sure I don't believe three so
I don't who knows I guess it just
depends on how badly you know they spend
all this money already right it's just
like how badly do you want to keep
marketing I mean I guess you don't have
to you can cancel flights in hotels but
still you bought the space floor space
is the most expensive part by far you
probably already pay for the like the
booth and everything which is also super
expensive how much time would have been
put into making that playable right demo
like polishing that demo I feel bad for
the developers the dev team actually I
was gonna say like we could hear
something else like happening with that
PlayStation Store
maybe yeah sure I mean sure yeah sure
those demos will be going around
regardless for a while last one came out
and that was when still in the age of
debug yes threes we had a disk that had
oh yeah a bug disc with the demos I've
lost to us on and it was um the town the
bit with Bill and that was just like the
demo and it was awesome and you could
have it and play it in the comfort of
your own Oh didn't even have to go to a
trade show you know like the other thing
with packs though is like they have
stuff like what your time I calculate
the packs 10 that they do worry about
you're really showcases like games that
end up being big like the maw list from
pax 10 which is by the guys who made a
explosion man they made it like a couple
other really big indie games and then
yeah miss Bozeman yes and then also I
think like the first time shovel knight
was shown was that pax hmm so like there
are games that just really blow up that
first
the pure packs scolese was the same yeah
yeah no Chang game great game great game
not a good not a great game that's why I
played it at least he gave a shot I I
gave it a full shot I finished the game
no game is for everybody let's just call
these news excellence uh I don't know if
you're saying this delay just really
played it I don't I can't tell did you
play this goalie zoom a hundred percent
okay what you think of it I loves it
I just I found the writing so
pretentious it bothered me I like I mean
I don't know like I just know it's like
do you have a friend who like thinks
they know it all and they use big words
just for the sake of using big words but
they don't sound any smarter for using
it's just they think they do this game
is the embodiment of that friend to me
I'll see I think disk Elysium who knows
the meaning of the things that's saying
though which would be the difference
between that kind of person in the game
I mean I think it does too but I think
those the person who does that knows the
meaning of those words it's just more it
just sounds pretentious because they
don't need to do it I don't know I just
I'm glad that you loved it and I fully
stand by a game spa's ten out of ten
fully stand by I don't know it's just
like I it just wasn't for me and that's
fine I know like a lot of people love it
like I was talking about roommate about
it's like I think it'd be more up his
alley and I was like honestly like I
recommend he play it and I'm like RPG
mechanics of it are good I totally was
just messing with you I you were free to
not like the game I just saw on that we
just we talked about it so much altering
our into the year did you ever like like
Jake loved it yeah a lot which is so
it's more in I'm really the outsider the
outcasts here because you're so much
actually it's because she's becoming a
middling show on HBO I regret did you
spend too much time now focusing on the
outsider just put the camera there doing
they're doing the Oh God we signed up
for ten episodes and I don't know if we
can do that it's frustrating sure I hope
it they'll on the ending other news this
is a Peter Brown suggestion Nintendo
Virtual Console he's adding so snez so
yes mate I'm free so free sneza Anna's
games for switch online any of these
because I never had either of these
consoles growing after I didn't either
what I had PC PlayStation 1 ps2 okay
Genesis yeah I mean there's a Genesis
people I
I was lucky like I I got a Super
Nintendo first but I saved up for like a
year of my allowances to get his Sega
Genesis I was able to have both so you
might at that point in my life my
parents just we added just make we had
it because they wanted it but with my
parents looking it's why we had PC
because my dad wanted to play things
like that's why I had earned ones yeah
my god bought a new PC just okay still a
game wouldn't run worms so he point a
whole new PC just for it love you dad
sounds like a good guy yes I bought him
it was actually very sweet for Christmas
he asked me for some games that were
like missed
yeah and Riven so I set him up with a
steam account and I bought him the room
one and two yeah good choices
the they were there is a game that the
people who made missed made in like 2011
yeah the name unfortunate hits PC
doesn't run it he's annoyed it got um
portal 1 and 2 yeah cuz you could tell
there was a sale on I got him like seven
games and then the other one was that
game that's basically missed where
you're sort of like a robot yeah you
move things around have very portal II
Oh begins it's like a tea is a tea I
don't remember it's gonna come back to
me sort of midway through um I think I
know what you're talking about but like
have have you play room escape games
your dad that the room is kind of like
listen not escape rooms they go to in
real life
escape games like Crimson rumor Viridian
room no okay here's your recommendation
from me it's here dad dad I think like
take back to him these are free flash
games neutral escape and mild escape
search for those online mmm like they're
so good puzzle II type of games like
Miss but you're stuck in a room and just
have to figure out how to get out and I
said yeah he'd be spared there is so
good like the room took from that genre
but like yeah those two specifically
might escape a neutral escape I think
are the best
I love escape rooms I'm really really
passionate about this I'm so excited
yeah yeah even though the escape rooms
in 99 are very good I just like the
story of it like it's a bad escape room
game with a cool story way it's a dragon
dragon yeah a copy with the name of that
game and all I can hear my head is
transdermal celebration by Wien cuz it
sounds mean yes like Talos principle
pals principle and neither was a team
thank you teleports we got there but
anyway cousin Wilbur Nintendo so Brown
please tell us about these games so pop
and twin be it's a Konami shooter that's
fine
it looks great if you have a friend to
play with looks like a great co-op
shooter game to me
sure top down it's fine I play I play a
lot of shmups okay I won't play with you
soon B is a bit basic and in my realm
smash tennis a fine game that didn't get
a release in the u.s. mmm shadow with a
ninja okay this is the one to get
excited about I've been wanting to play
this for a long time this is a talk
about good co-op game okay
Ninja Gaiden was sort of like the
blueprint for 8-bit ninja games like
there were a lot of other ninja games on
the NES Ninja Gaiden was the one that
really stuck and shadow of the ninja is
like okay what if we refined it made it
less [ __ ] and we sort of like added
a bit of like like like urban like
cybernetic like kind of the vile kind of
like you know sinister we're more of a
sinister flair to it I suppose
none of your verbs none of your
adjectives for all my my people out
there it's like a title game made by
natsume so okay first of all ninja
gaiden [ __ ] yeah that's true
that's very the first two games are
grade three takes it to an extreme Ria's
stupid that doesn't count but like yeah
I like I've made it a habit of
collecting all the ninja games on the
NES because there was a game I loved but
then when I was a kid I've rented from
Blockbuster and had never found it again
and I remembered it having a ninja so I
bought every ninja game and I miss
shadow of the ninja and it turns out the
game was Jackie Chan Khong sir I'm so
good I have to say I'm bursting up the
seams so you got ninja gated one energy
gating two ninja gaiden 3 and cruisin
USA yes
that's real easy thank you I really
appreciate that unlike so many because
its iconic so anyway which is a
wonderful game or yeah shadow of the
ninja
you should get it's not you should buy
it on your yes I'll take your
recognition yeah actually I actually
like boxed NES games in Super Nintendo
games I'm sorry ok why well yes hardest
word is a very expensive hobby where
does the scariest thing can I sell you
some games yeah are you sure you want
them complete do you have them on NES
and SNES I have like 90 NES games for
sale they're not complete though ah yeah
as long as it has the box that's really
what I'm looking for
no just cards I stay in the box I'm
quite well I'm not complete like I said
cardboard scares but maybe you don't
have the instruction manual I don't know
I have some instruction manuals but no I
don't like boxes they terrify the [ __ ]
out of me it's that's actually a pretty
decent game yeah it literally it's like
- like speedboats kind of racing like
throwing things at each other I missed
what these games are they're the free
SNES and mineus games it's not free if
you're a Nintendo online subscribers
they get added so you're sort of a lot
minute game on times
we plan tompa Tama plan I would I would
advise you and I'm saying this as
someone who's been collecting games for
almost twenty years
you should watch not for resale assume
documentary that just came out yeah
it'll give you some introspection
regarding collecting not to diminish why
you want your NES games complete because
it's not to sell them right it's just
for me but why because I look at my
collection and it's games that mean a
lot to me and it makes me had every NES
game means a lot to the ones that I buy
I don't buy every NES oh I'm sorry I
thought you wanted every NES game no no
ok ok I think I just buy the ones that
mean a lot to watch it watch a good
documentary it definitely like I'm so
sort of like I was gushing about
Hardware before I've gotten to the point
where it's like my collection was never
about quantity it was always about
quality like games that I would like to
play eventually if I haven't played them
already or ones I love a lot now I just
want to keep the ones I love a lot and
really focus on the hardware but this
documentary really focuses in on the why
people collect why people run use video
game stores yeah and sort of how they
survive and rationalize that within the
modern gaming landscape where nostalgia
is so powerful it's a it's pretty
interesting look but I I'm glad you're
not collecting everyone knows otherwise
I would say I don't have the money man
no I know yeah that's ridiculous
yes like yeah like maybe once a year
I'll go buy like three games because
it's like a hundred bucks a game for
like an old game yeah sometimes less
right yes I'm well depending on the game
like Chrono Trigger was like 150 200
bucks
sure sure at the box but I got really
lucky once I was on the bomb cast we
were talking about my game collecting
and they're like what's your white whale
and it's like it's not the most rare
expensive thing I just want a mint box
copy of super metroid
that's my throw my favorite games when i
think of a retro game it's like the one
I kind of mm-hm that's the iconic one
for me I got an email from the audience
member like two days later it was like
hey Jan the bomb cast I have a box that
I flattened when I bought it back in the
90s do you want it and I was like I mean
I pay you for it he's like no I don't
anyway we've back and forth line
fighting like sure I I have a mint day
one super
trade box and it just means the world to
me mostly giant bomb cast if you want to
have me honest I can gonna have that
viewer hit me up it was pretty special
yeah so it's like it it's a good duel
sort of thing for me you know it's like
one man's garbage another man's treasure
you know he was selling his stuff he was
like I did I got the sense that this
would mean a lot to you and that's
that's why I want to give it to ya did
you know Super Metroid is Jake's
favorite game Jake yeah who's Jake
Decker I had a similar experience
shout-out to Errol moss I had talked
about on a podcast forever ago
how I have lost my ancient Mew card like
I think that is one of the most
thoughtful things as like mentioning
something offhand and people like you
know what I think you would really like
that even it's not if you were asked
directly and somebody's like you know
what I have that thing and I don't need
that thing mm-hmm look that is that is
so as such a beautiful story to me I was
shocked when I looked at it it was one
of those things where it's like do I
need to go through the steps to verify
that this is real so I know it's real
yeah cuz mm one almost looks like the
reproduction yeah yeah but I mean I've
been around this stuff intimately for so
long and there's really just a couple
telltale signs and it was like this is
it this is the real [ __ ] thing that's
so cool man Congrats yeah it's like one
of those things that I will never sell
not because someone gave it to me
because if the game it is right yeah
happy for me I got mmm not that it
matters I'm just more intro respecting
that's a good podcast question yeah so
what's your gaming white whale in terms
of like the game that you want or that
you know so ass about podcast against
what a calm if you want to email what's
a game yeah because kind of funny do a
nice thing when the Vita was like they
do this thing where they get people who
are looking to get the platinum trophy
on things they'll say and they'll hook
people up so that'd be nice to do what
is yours Lucy my gaming white whale
there is
hmm I don't know I should have never
really thought about great taste thought
I died yeah I'll come back to this next
week cuz I've never really thought about
it I mean having a having moved so many
times I've become pretty ruthless at
culling yeah all of my gaming boxes
example and I just have a big disc
sleeve yeah yeah I actually I have an
answer but I it's like I had an answer
because I got it
I never I'd like I've never been like I
don't need a mint-condition thing um but
I used to buy every pokemon game like I
used to like I would get red blue and
yellow yeah I did not have friends and I
would trade it myself my brother wasn't
into Pokemon so like eventually like he
like I got sapphire and he got Ruby but
then I inherited his Ruby because he
didn't really play it anyway I always
wanted a pokemon green because that was
like the one Pokemon came I couldn't get
here yeah and my last trip to Japan I
got a box copy of Pokemon was it from
super potato it was not from super
potato it was from a random game store
in Shinjuku nice yeah I was so excited
and John Luke got me a box copy pokemon
yellow so I think the last one I would
really want is crystal cuz crystals my
favorite like from nostalgia purposes
the first Pokemon game you could play as
a girl and it was really important to me
I it was actually the first Pokemon game
I played because I didn't want to play a
game until I could play as a girl then I
went back and played red blue and yellow
I was like eight I was just like suck
I want to be girl and I was upset um
I've always been I've always been like
this and I think lastly it's all Pokemon
I I don't have black or black - I only
have white and white - but they're like
$100 or something mm-hmm weird why are
they expensive
I don't know the DS Pokemon games are
really close you're talking really like
they're really hard to get the you don't
help you because that doesn't sound
right to me okay I need to be that guy
who's like let me let me explain how to
get by this girl I'm befuddled by this
HeartGold and SoulSilver if you want
them with a poco Walker it's like $300
super expensive I still have my original
Harken somenone hey cuz I just gathering
just in my mum's place yeah mines at my
parents place but um you don't know that
your mom is just they're using that
playing those games haha game of steps
in I regret not getting black and black
too because they there's a like a
different location in black and white
yeah and I prefer the city mmm thing and
remember which one I got that generation
is like it's based on New York and yeah
in a lot of ways anyway that's the last
one I should talk about Animal Crossing
let's let's so out of all of us here
transparency you're there anyone who's
watched the direct um was it everything
you hoped for and more um I would say
like I was actually very nervous about
New Horizons I was worried it would be
up until now I was worried it would be
too similar to pocket camp um I didn't I
really fell off a [ __ ] camp and it's
because of the it's really hard to
explain the subtle differences between
like a main Animal Crossing game and
pocket camp it was pocket camp the one
that was on the cell phones yeah okay
and it's it's like a part of it is
because it had like the mobile like
microtransaction thing like you have to
wait five hours for this thing to happen
and it's like in Maine Animal Crossing
games you have to wait because it's real
time but it doesn't feel the same yeah
it's a very intangible thing to me and I
don't quite have the vocabulary you're
like fully because I didn't play enough
pocket pocket camp to fully explain what
didn't click with me but part of it was
the emphasis on my friendship with
villagers and so that's something I was
concerned about in New Horizons the
deserted island theme like I really like
Animal Crossing because my whole my
whole life I wanted to move to like a
farm like get away from I I'm gonna
sound really bratty for a second I grew
up by the beach I hate the beach I hate
I hate swimming
I am super pale I can be out in the Sun
for like 15 minutes and I just wanted to
live like in a forest I wanted to go
somewhere with trees I didn't have any
trees on the street I grew
up on and so I was so drawn to animal
crossing because it was it was like a
town that my dad grew up in in the
Midwest like Harvest Moon would be your
jam - it sure is and like I said earlier
is a starting value yesterday and so I
was nervous about the island thing
because I was just like that's just
never I've never wanted to like move to
paradise like my dream isn't moving to a
farm in the middle of nowhere and being
like look at all those cows like I just
am NOT I'm not like I can't wait to move
to Bali so um I the the direct and I
also played about half an hour of New
Horizons from the very beginning so I
just like started in a new island
essentially and it really s waged my
fears a lot I think one of the biggest
things is that the game kind of
emphasizes friendship right away and
that's one of the biggest things I love
about Animal Crossing is meeting the
villages villagers in your town and
slowly befriending them and sending them
letters and and just cute little
interactions like that and the like
right away you you get to the island
basically the the premise is Tom Nook
has a new corporation where he has kind
of like a timeshare on this island where
he's like come up on this deserted
island together it's my new business
venture and it's only you and two other
villagers to start which is fewer
villagers then you would start with in a
previous family usually was like five
yeah and I think the max is like eight
or something um so the only two I got
dear drink heaven so for those who know
Dierdre Dierdre she's beautiful the
graphics are really good anyway I'll get
there but you you like the first thing
is like we're gonna have a big like
ceremony to welcome everybody and we're
gonna work together we're gonna have
this like little party because we only
have each other here and like we're like
we're gonna build our relationships here
and I it sounds silly that like just the
the dialogues these animals give you can
set that tone but it really does and I
was like okay everything's gonna be okay
and I was worried about the crafting but
um it doesn't replace the things that
that you're used to an animal crossing'
like checking the store every day for
new furniture one of the things that we
learned in the direct is that you can
upgrade to buildings like the nook's
cranny April sisters the museum is
confirmed the campsite from the new leaf
DLC museum is what I care about the most
by far basically you're not just moving
to a desert island and like ditching
everything you're building your own
Animal Crossing village up and you can
still like go to the next cranny and buy
furniture and there's gonna be furniture
there that like you can't craft so it's
not like everything you're just craft
which is the case in Puckett camp
basically so there's like little things
that that like that made me like okay
I'm fully excited now I was nervous now
I'm excited so how did the crafting
system work exactly so it's you get like
a Nook phone like a smartphone and the
game is really cute it's like do you own
a smartphone because obviously there's
gonna be children who have never used a
smartphone before yeah oh it's you can
be like oh I already have one which is
really cute but it's like the Nook phone
and of course Tom Nook Tom Nook is like
the world's biggest capitalist he like
provides you the phone and stuff and one
of the apps is the DIY app and at the
beginning you you eventually can upgrade
this building to the town hall but you
get like resident services and you go
there and Tom Nook hosts free workshops
right he teaches you how to DIY and then
from once you take the first one
you can then like you'll get a DIY
recipe that'll be like here's how you
craft a workbench and then you can
upload that to you can like learn the
recipe and it's in your app yeah but I
actually like how the phone is
integrated it kind of sounds like too
contemporary or something but there's
like a you get like nook mileage points
like a typical like airline mileage
thing from like oh I talked to everybody
today I get miles and then the miles can
be used to pay off your debt because you
took this trip like a timeshare hahaha
and so you got to use your miles to pay
off the airplane fees cool do you Peter
is gonna die
I just it's not your cup of tea
no I I I like the first animal crossing
I just haven't
what is it I don't know it has only
washed over me the way that like it I
feel like it has some people mm-hmm
so maybe the switch one will do it for
me because it's been a long time since
I've really tried yeah I love the doom
to err account basically scanning animal
crossing yeah they've really cuz
obviously they come out on the same day
and the doom to our account is really
leaning into it yeah part of them the
doom subreddit people are like making
Animal Crossing like doom crossover art
that's great and it's really wholesome
good we have a whole article about it
like compiling some of the best on fan
art but like it's really wholesome how
the doom community is like we're going
to hell like capitalism yeah yeah and
it's interesting cuz the direct starts
with like this recap of stuff we already
knew but if you weren't like really
paying attention you probably didn't
know some of it one of the things is
that like you can choose for the first
time whether you're in the northern or
southern hemisphere something they
mentioned kind of offhanded shoes which
way the toilet flushes exactly all right
that's something they mentioned kind of
offhand during like a treehouse stream
after the direct during e3 2019 and they
literally just like you could choose and
then like that kind of brush past I
watched I rewatched it today just to be
sure nice and but I think it's really
cool because I was thinking about you
know we have a whole team of colleagues
in Australia I'm like I don't think any
of them are particularly named Animal
Crossing but if they were for the first
time it's like oh it's a winter when
it's winter for me right exactly um and
that's one of the things that is cool
about the real time stuff in Animal
Crossing is you're like like I really
like winter time and now I got wild
world was my favorite Animal Crossing
for a really long time I played it every
day for like two years and I first got
it for Christmas so wintertime it
doesn't feel complete with Anna at
without Animal Crossing to me I'm so
excited I like can't even speak and
it's it's just it I think that's
important for other people too and it's
nice to see one of those choices but
they also had new stuff in the direct do
you feel like there's more to do
throughout the day because that's the
one thing I ran into with Animal
Crossing is like I play for five minutes
and be like I guess that's it
I guess I'm done so yeah I'm just
curious um I think one of the big things
that like one of the new things they
revealed is you can it's called the
island designer app I believe and it's
basically a construction mode you can
enter into and you can basically
terraform your island so you can like oh
I don't like that a cliff is here I'm
gonna add more land so it the land
stretches out longer or I'm gonna add a
river here you can change the terrain of
the island for the first time and like I
could spend so much time making it
perfect like one thing one of my biggest
regrets in life in life was resetting my
animal crossing new leaf town after a
breakup because I was like all my
villagers are talking about you and I
broke up with him but I was I need a new
start and I restarted my Animal Crossing
town and I never settled on a new town I
look at the map be like I'm gonna choose
this one and they still have that in
this you can choose between yeah four
options I just never found one that was
perfect for me
I was so picky and now like you can
literally just be like you know it I
don't like that those rivers here
anymore I'm gonna fix it by I went
through an animal crossing breakup and
after the breakup I like went into my
ex-girlfriends Animal Crossing house and
stole all of her stuff six and then we
got back together a couple months later
she was like where's all my stuff and I
was like
that's crazy like I bet like you know
like Bob is really off the shit's like
Tom Nook really repossessed all your
[ __ ] is crazy
she's has some of the collections that I
needed to complete I was like I need to
complete my collection yes yeah yeah no
that's very relatable but yeah so I one
of the big things and I know how this
sounds
is paths creating paths so I don't know
if you ever created a path in your town
in previous Animal Crossing games and if
you did that I have it so it didn't
start it wasn't a Gamecube in wild world
I think starting in wild world or no
maybe city folk you could like if you
ran over the same places it would wear
down the grass so grass where was
introduces a mechanic and you could if
you like ran along the same paths you
could create your own art of like oh
these are my specialty I probably walk
on these or you could get patterns of
like bricks and then like stand into
place select go to patterns hit the
pattern you want place and then move and
do that and it was like the most painful
thing mmm I I did I did this okay you
survived so much time being and then if
you wanted a new pattern and you got a
new one of you downloaded a new one I
like it like oh I got a new shirt now
all of your all of the bricks are shirts
like it was the worst bullsháá haha are
you are you serious thank you yes so
anyway through the island designer app
there's now just like a separate path
menu and you can easily lay paths and
then make them curved or squared people
are gonna go apeshit but what if I want
brick shirts you can still have brick
shirts
okay what about shirt bricks
shooting bricks rain
those were some big things there's a a
tool selection wheel like a weapon wheel
mm-hmm tool time it's tool time it's
tool time
and it's unlockable you there's like
stuff you can unlock as rewards through
the Nook my Hodja program
I'm hit I've hit platinum stea Samia the
mileage program but yeah so you can like
unlocks a mile-high club one of the
things you can unlock is a tool
selection wheel like a weapon wheel so
you don't have to like click through the
d-pad or go into your menu it's like
little stuff but I'm so pumped mm-hm and
as everyone is aware the villagers can
wear long sleeve shirts now finally our
presidency it gets cold and deserted
Islands in the tropics sometimes you
need a long summer in the northern
hemisphere
yeah
all right let's get on to listen to
questions let's speed through these
because we've been going for like an
hour and 20 and also we're having a look
at a nightmare oh and also I'm wearing
high-waisted jeans of how to be me - I
need to pee oh you - okay I certainly do
that that's mine your subtle my life
hack so email us
after dr. podcast at Gamescom I know
that I looked even though we say every
week I feel bad this isn't a question
this is um this is a iTunes review
please review us on iTunes especially if
you leave great reviews like this one
which is five stars from J smash I just
want to read a lot cuz it really made me
laugh one of my co-workers was being
super annoying the other day so I put in
my headphones and started listening to
GameSpot after dark and Wow this podcast
works wonders not only did it drown out
the Intolerable voice of my bothersome
coworker but it filled my ear holes with
something much more tolerable to listen
to ten out of ten would recommend deca
and crew are there for you PS it's fun
fact Friday did you know a man named
child Charles Osborne had the hiccups
for 68 years from 1922 to 1919 they
started after a 300-pound hog fell on
top of him while he was getting ready to
slaughter it a hiccup stopped and he was
96 about a year before he died what a
life
PBS I'm not characters yet so here's a
bonus fact did you know in England in
the 1880s pants was considered a dirty
word now you know and knowing is half
the battle
good game and good day
Dave gonna read this question from Sean
from Houston hey Dirk crew been
listening since episode one and I love
the show you guys make my Monday workday
that much easier to get through so
thanks I'm writing him because on last
week's episode Lucy says something that
hit me and made me curious
she has misophonia do I pronounce that
correctly I don't know I say me cell
phone Ian misophonia excuse me but I've
only ever seen it written down I have it
so then we have a comas acquaintance of
a conversation of have you been dying
from us drinking the beers next to you
know so it's it's actually I didn't know
what it was
until a few years ago knowing what it
was is giving me the power to actually
be aware of my reactions to it and learn
how to cope with it so Anna says knowing
is half the battle from the context I
figured it was about the mouth noises
happening and I googled it
what the hell I've been fighting this
thing my whole life and never knew it
had a name I get so irrationally angry
at people when I hear them eat or drink
I don't mean to and almost never say
anything about it because well am I
supposed to say stop eating yes spike
that we have I remember one time I
yelled at my then-girlfriend to stop
eating and then she broke up with me and
immediately felt like the absolute and
immediately felt like absolute [ __ ]
luckily she understood yes she didn't
break up with him over this anyways this
led me to a question for you all is
there anything that makes you
irrationally angry and has it ever
gotten you in trouble
calli thanks for all you do keep it up
Sean Houston I thought their name was
Sean Houston it's Sean from he's jump
makes a lot more sense well anyway I
maybe for people who didn't listen to
last week's episode misophonia it's it's
the irritation from mouth noises it's
more than that I mean it's more it is a
primal reaction it's it's like I what I
might I don't get it from nails on a
chalkboard but it's that classic it's
repetitive stimulus that you have no
control over that sends you into a fit
of rage because you fixate upon it it's
a form of OCD mm-hmm is it I just
thought it was not liking those noises
I'm fine with some eating sounds but
there are things that just really just
send a shiver down my spine like what
eating sounds crunching okay so knows
Captain Crunch around you know Rice
Krispies nuts mm-hmm so for me like I
have it
crunching doesn't bother me and that's
not the sort of thing it's the it has to
do with the repetition mm-hmm so if it's
like if I was like tapping my foot yes
and even if I didn't hear it if I saw if
I saw it in the corner of my eye that's
enough to trigger it as well I mean so
funny--i translates to the hatred of
sound but it's more than just that
that's why I said stimulus
because it can even be visual like for
example a girlfriend used to like like
just have like a random like kind of
fidget that we had to like work through
like I had to be like I am really upset
by what you're doing and I know it's
stupid but we need to talk about it
because if I don't address it I'm gonna
like lose it and we had to like cope
with the like you're being crazy I was
like yeah I know but this is just what
I'm dealing with
yeah it's it's a whole suite of things
for example my dad used to his jaw used
to click hmm so it almost becomes a
mental game as well because it's like
it's the stimulus but it's what you do
with that stimulus so sometimes if it's
the the eating thing it's like oh they
don't know what they're doing what's
their problem why do they keep doing
that don't they realize you almost get
this like you want to do it back at them
the only way to cope is to like
aggressively do it back my dad he used
to chew and his job would click I
thought he was biting everything super
hard I didn't know his jaw was clicking
and I used to sit there just stare at
him be like you're just eating bread why
are you biting it with all your force it
took my parents never understood what it
was it took 30 years to figure it out
didn't come to them with the revelation
like oh my god
I did kind of explain it to them but
I've had to rationalize it more with
myself than anyone else because it's
been a thing that's been very
challenging up until the last two years
so that makes both of you irrationally
angry Kali do you have anything
specifically as Sean asked I mean Thomas
what commas do so many people don't know
how to use commas and the thing is the
thing is I know that grammar is made up
I know it's made up I know it's classist
hmm to care but hmm
lanky dumpy it's a question for like
when the comma
I'd be so bad please I really I get I
can't read anything without editing it I
it's I mean it's part of my job is of
the day and I thing is like I'm aware
like I would never judge I would never
be like you're not smart because you
don't know how to use a comma but I look
at it and I'm like why the why did you
put a colon there that's not where you
would do that like how do you and it
seems like because the rules of grammar
the rules of grammar seem like math to
me there so I just know the rules like I
just know like like new you know I I'm
sorry this o is too many commas more
annoying or to view commas just didn't
like any like I'm just like how do you
not on your statements I need to be an
adult right now and actually leave the
room to go to the bathroom and I'm
jealous I'm hosting this thing I called
you that you go we can't cut we'd like
to be no we can't fake it with a 1/2 a
why I mean okay you go and then no
question can you skip to Robert J's
question here
hey yes it's it's short blast cows cows
daddy hello after dark crew I sometimes
record my game sessions but hearing my
voice always deters me from revisiting
them since this is a podcast you ever
feel uncomfortable by listening to your
own voice do you do anything to overcome
that feeling thank you for reading and
keep up the good work sincerely Robert J
I am I hate listening to and seeing
myself and realizing that I'm a person
that other people can perceive you know
yeah what you exist like wow other
people like like I have to like look at
me and like see that I am a person I
hate listening to my voice now because
Tam posted a video literally yesterday
on Twitter of us playing overwatch from
2016 and I listened to it and I was like
oh my god what's happened to my accent
no yeah it's I sound like a completely
different person and I can't help that
I'm one of those people who takes in the
accents of people around me I've also
seen lived in America for 18 months all
my friends are American my wafers
American like everyone's American around
me and so my voice get takes on these
inter nations I don't know just
everyone's American
look I do I owe the thing is I also
osmosis accents and so when tomorrow
says something mean I don't hear I'm
like wow I feel so bad but I can't help
it you know and so yeah listening to
your voice - tearing - tearing you from
listening to your game recordings don't
I do that it's just it's just exposure
yeah listening to it you get used to
your own voice it just sounds weird
because when you listen to your own
voice as you're speaking you're hearing
it from inside that happens because
you're hearing it reverberating through
bone and when you listen it to it back
you're hearing it reverberate through
normal sound waves so you're hearing
your own voice through bones don't just
remember like it could be bad my quality
like I've been doing when I first heard
my voice like 15 years ago on a camera
stuff I was like mortified by what I
sounded like but now like I've been
doing stuff on camera and like vo and
all that for ten years so like I
sometimes I'm like wow my voice sounds
like crap but I know it's a bad mic
because I know what my voice sounds like
at this point and you kind of know and
you can tell that - so that helps just
but yeah like you says just the more you
do it the more you hear the more you get
used to you're okay with it unless
you're Lucy who loses a really cool
accent it turns into a crap accent don't
worry I'm bursting at the seams you
wonder why I'm gripping this because I
just feel like this is a grandpa Simpson
situation Dave wagon people find you on
life
Dave control You Tube GameSpot universe
also YouTube day at the decline on
Twitter everybody speaking slowly yes if
I survive you can find me at BC Brown on
Twitter
I really see James games Dave thank you
so much for joining us it's nice house
I'm just go this week
thank you everyone else for watching
we'll be back again next week and Jake
will be back to have a steadier hand on
the terrace we love you bye-bye
[Music]